again
this is not financial advice disclaimer
but
uh let me ask so you in terms of
investment advice on bitcoin
so you see bitcoins potentially not just
the thing that you sp
speculate over like buy and sell buy and
sell buy and sell
but it's something that you can just buy
only and i believe
i've heard that you own uh quite a large
percentage of you of
your wealth in in bitcoin and you're
basically buying only
yeah and storing long term so that's
something that's a legitimate
way to approach bitcoin in your
recommendation go to other cultures so
if we remove ourselves from the western
world culture of
uh investing and gamification of
financial markets and the
financialization of everything
let's say we go to uh the culture of
india
for hundreds if not thousands of years
families basically
saved their wealth in gold and in
jewelry and in these hard assets
with the expectation to pass it on to
the next generation
and so it would be blasphemous to sell
the family's gold
in that culture right you know your your
great grandfather gave to your
grandfather your grandfather gave it to
your father your father gave it to you
right and so in that culture
the long-term kind of uh holding
is the default i think that what bitcoin
has presented again is a digital
application
of the exact same thing which is that
while everything else in the world is
being devalued that is denominated in a
uh a currency that is being inflated
away
whether it's quickly or not this finite
supply this scarce asset
ends up accruing more and more value
over time right and so
um i think that for me personally um
i've got you know over 95 of my net
worth that's in this
90 over 95 percent of your net worth
there's two important caveats to this
one
is i didn't you know buy some bitcoin in
2011 or 12
right and then also it appreciated a
bunch and it grew into that but
from a cost basis perspective you know i
put 100 and now it's
a ton of money instead what i did was i
basically in 2018
um saw bitcoin from a us dollar price
standpoint was falling and falling and
falling and in december of 2018 i still
take about 50
of my net worth and convert it from
dollar denominated assets into bitcoin
so it's a very kind of intentional
decision with a very specific view on
the world as to like why i was doing it
i then essentially just let it sit there
grow whatever
until uh the spring of 2020.
and when i saw the government step in
and start to say hey we're going to
really be aggressive in terms of
interest rate manipulation and
quantitative easing
i then decided to go ahead and take
basically the remainder and start to
convert it as well so i became very
aggressive in doing that and so
the way that i look at it is that's
actually my savings
right and so in some weird way if i said
to you know what's the dollar worth
you'd say well
a one dollar bill's worth one dollar
right bitcoin to me i denominate my
wealth in bitcoin
so i think of one bitcoin is worth one
bitcoin not one bitcoin is worth sixty
thousand or fifty five thousand or
seventy thousand right i denominate
everything in bitcoin when i make a
purchase
in my head i'm calculating how much
bitcoin am i spending right now
right well guess what happens when you
have a devaluing currency as the
denominator
it doesn't matter right like you're
financially incentivized to spend or
invest right to consume
uh when you have an appreciating
currency
all of a sudden you become much less
consumptive
behavior yeah because you're actually
trading off
future purchasing power yeah for the
consumption today
it's fascinating to think that if if uh
when you move about this world you think
in bitcoin
you behave differently is if you think
in dollars
that's really fascinating people but but
here's the thing is
the last 50 years or so is actually the
outlier
in history most people used to think
this way yeah it's only when a fiat
currency got introduced
that one argument the positive argument
or perspective
is there was an explosion in growth
but really it's because there was a
financial incentive to consume yeah
right and there's nobody better in the
world than the united states
at consuming and we consume anything and
everything
and if you want to see a great example
look at how big the coca-colas are at
mcdonald's
you know you go to other places they
don't serve them that big and so
the other example or the negative
argument
is we have to consume
because if not you end up being the
bottom 45
of americans that held no investable
assets and actually are just having
their wealth devalued away
so holding the dollars end up being a
very bad
economic decision and so when you then
switch to this
sound money you say wait a second why
would i
if today i can trade one bitcoin you
know back in
october of last year one bitcoin for 10
000 us dollars
why would i spend that if at some point
in the future whether it's
a month from now or 10 years from now i
could trade it for
something much much more than that you
just
become much more of a um uh
anti-consumer and much more of a
long-term thinker
yeah from the individual perspective
that's pretty powerful i wonder i mean
i think that's an interesting debate
what's better for the long-term economy
no uh better for the growth of the
civilization because capitalism
is fascinating uh it seems to
it seems to work pretty well there's
this kind of
like eric weinstein says that
one of the problems is for the past
several decades this whole
economy society is built on the idea
that we have to keep growing
like it depends on that idea and it's a
good question whether that's going to
result in huge problems or if like a
college student on a deadline
the the dependence on growth will mean
that we'll have to grow
like the fear of death will force us to
grow
but i think there's a false equivalency
between um
we're dependent on growth and then if
the world was denominated and sound
money
we don't grow what i think ends up
happening is
we remove a lot of the society's
yeah
because right now when the money is free
or
the currency is free you come up with
all kinds of crazy stuff and people will
give it to you
right when all of a sudden it's really
really
valued by the population the decisions
are better
yeah you have to provide real value in
the goods and services you provide
to get them to give it to you there's
less room for corruption less room for
manipulation that's
and like that's not actually productive
yeah uh
definitely so you said you moved a lot
of
your investment into bitcoin and is
there
uh when you look so you're a special
human being in many ways uh so you're
like a strategic thinker but you're also
like a deep thinker about this whole
thing but when you look at a regular
pleb like me
uh in terms of just investing and moving
into
uh thinking about cryptocurrency is
there a strategy that you recommend
what are the different options about
investing into bitcoin
yeah so i think that there's just uh
kind of timeless advice when it comes to
uh investing or acquiring an asset in
general uh dollar cost averaging
is usually the best way to think about
it and what i mean by that is
um most people don't just have a pile of
currency sitting there right it's not
like they have a million dollars sitting
in their banks like what do i do with it
uh that situation aside uh what happens
is they
trade their hours and their effort for
currency and so as they get paid every
two weeks let's say
um the best way to acquire bitcoin
without having to worry about timing
markets and being a professional trader
is to simply take whatever the
percentage is that you want and
to buy bitcoin when you get your
paycheck so if you get paid on the first
and 15th of every month
on that day you should go take you know
let's say it's three percent of your
paycheck
take three percent go buy bitcoin don't
worry about what the price is just do
that over time
and the reason why that's important is
um if in december of 2017
when bitcoin is at 20 000 it was the
height of kind of this last
uh big upwards movement you had taken
all of your money
and you had put it into bitcoin you
would have had to wait almost three
years
just to get back to quote-unquote break
even in us dollar terms
if at the same time you had simply
bought
then and over the next three years
bought every two weeks
you would have been up hundreds of
percent three years later
because what ended up happening was you
bought a bunch of bitcoin when it was at
12 10 9 8 3 4
5 5 5 you know all the way back up on
the other side
and so dollar cost averaging is one of
these weird things that uh it almost
sounds too easy
but what we find is in america we have a
lack of financial education
and so rather than try to be smarter
than markets what most people are better
off doing is just saying hey
set your what's called an asset
allocation plan i want
30 in stocks i want 10 real estate i
want this this whatever
and every time you get your paycheck
just think of it as a savings account
right just put it in based on those
percentages and don't think about it
and over a long enough period of time
what we find is
almost anyone in the united states right
there's exceptions but almost anyone in
the united states
can become a millionaire in their
lifetime if they follow these plans and
have that long-term view and they allow
compounding to work for them
and so don't look at the price of
bitcoin and all that kind of stuff just
pick a
specific time specific day that you just
buy
and you just keep buying that's probably
good investment advice across any kind
of assets
it's like if you don't believe in
bitcoin and you just want to let's say
you just want to do the s p 500 yeah
you shouldn't try to time the market of
the s p 500 either right you should just
every two weeks you should just buy
something over a 20 year period
you're gonna end up buying it at all
kinds of different prices but you're
gonna get kind of a blended average
and the more important thing is the
compounding and the time in the market
then did you buy it at you know two
percent higher or lower than where you
bought it doesn't really matter and
buying often makes you i guess uh
resistant robust to the uh to the
volatility of the market or the
volatility the bitcoin price and so on
you